made with tender gourmet cuts of meat
and elevated yet simple all natural
ingredients crave jerky is a great
source of protein that's low in fat and
gluten free not to mention the range of
flavors is bold and imaginative they
have sweet Chipotle beef black cherry
barbecue pork and chili lime beef just
to name a few
so try one of craves bold tender flavors
like chili lime beef or black cherry
barbecue pork by going to crave jerky
calm crave with a que get 20% off when
you use the code grace welcome back to
another episode of not too deep with me
your host Grace and helping the first
day just want my mom to feel like okay
that I like my middle name Thank You mom
this is a very exciting episode again if
you are only listening to this episode a
quick reminder that we are now filming
these episodes and posting them on my
youtube channel youtube.com slash grace
Helbig today's episode is quite a
whirlwind quite a rollercoaster quite
sweaty but really fun I think that is
the full definition of our guest it's
Bert Kreischer who is a comedian travel
enthusiast just all-around kind of he'd
truly if you're listening you're not
seeing I'm wearing a shirt that has a
Tasmanian Devil on and I feel like he
fully embodies that character as a human
being and I could have talked to him for
hours and hours and hours but I'm gonna
get to it because Bert has a lot to say
about a lot of things and has come to
the table with the most amount of pants
shooting stories I've ever heard I
they are vivid to say the least enjoy
have you been in Germany of course okay
I've never been oh my god I love it
I've been to Oktoberfest but in Canada
there's like a small region in Canada
that's like the second biggest
Oktoberfest celebration and I had to do
it for like a gig that I had to go like
cover the festival yeah and it was just
13 hours of trying to interview drunk
people which is you know obviously great
I don't know it's worse people watching
people that aren't in Germany try to pay
homage to their German heritage or
Germans okay well one thing I did want
to one of the things I want to talk to
you about is you travel a ton yeah
obviously for stand-up you travel for
the shows that you've worked on what is
your worst most repressed travel memory
oh Jesus I mean I feel like you've lived
a thousand lives obviously yeah you know
I I'm one of those guys that I run hot
so like I can find I can find a reason
to love wherever I am okay I usually
find a reason I call that optimism yeah
yeah even in like the shittiest places
in the world I'm like I'm like well they
got a little like we were stuck in this
bar in Bari Italy we're waiting for a
shuttle
ferry to take us to Corfu mm-hm and I
had misjudged it we had to sit there for
another 10 hours and I was like guys we
just get blackout drunk and they're like
okay we can do that there's always an
option yeah I'm always but I think
probably the worst travel experience
I've ever had is whenever you get stuck
somewhere and you don't want to be there
yeah yeah like I got stuck in I got
stuck in the Mohegan Sun and a blizzard
oh yeah that's a mad lib sentence that
sucks yeah I got there and there was a
blizzard so all my shows were cancelled
right and the work that you were
supposed to do there got taken away from
you nine people showed up one of which
was a guy in a wheelchair who walked out
of my show in a wheelchair he rolled out
who I like he had the straw and
everything he was like you saw like a
Gatsby Braff and I was like I was like
really [ __ ] serious and he goes
you saw that's a very specific walkout
dude he was blowing himself out with a
straw in his wheelchair and still
cursing me out I mean that's almost kind
of a compliment in a way leh yeah but
then I had to run into him all night
because I wanted to [ __ ] casino so it
was just me and him well I mean that's
how friendships start I guess that's how
all my nightmares were that I can't get
home to my family
like that's my talk to a therapist about
that
I'm Meridian therapy but he's okay got
it
some of us aren't there yet no I had I
had a recent conversation with a couple
friends where I realized like how
terrible I am and how incapable I am
when we were talking about like Airport
bad travel scenarios and I was like I've
fallen asleep twice at my gate like 10
feet like my distance to this camera
from the gate fallen asleep woken up two
hours later and tried to board the
flight that was boarding in front of me
and then had the flight attendant go no
ma'am your flight was two hours ago and
I was telling this like very
colloquially to a bunch of women and
then realized like none of them could
relate to that because they're all very
professional I feel like you might have
those situations in your life
Omaha Steaks
love them go on this is one year ago one
year this is okay I'm on a tear I'm on a
tear I'm partying I went I went from
Stanhope's to New York no stand-ups to
Florida to New York and I end up doing a
one-nighter I used to these morning call
in sick to work shows where I'd have the
whole audience come in at 10:00 in the
morning they just drink they drink and
so I do that that night Chris Porter's
there me and him end up smoking pot in
his room all night long and drinking I
wake up in a panic I have barely packed
I wake up and it's the front desk going
sir your car's been here for over an
hour like oh my god I don't shower no by
the way I'm a more impulsive so I shower
and we're the exact same thing every day
when I fly okay I throw everything in
the bag I get my bags in the car I
literally have I'm let me joking at one
point I sat on the toilet I went Burt be
cool with missing this flight just slow
down and be comfortable missing this
flight and I went no cuz I had a party
planned at home
our friends at sunny and this is the
only direct flight for mobile is your
panic is missing you can getting home I
get in the I get the car service in the
Gers I'm sorry man I've been down I've
been trying to call you my phone's not
even plugged in right I go I go how much
time do we have he goes it takes 15
minutes to get to the airport and and
the your flight leaves is boarding in 10
oh my god just go the best you can this
guy's hauling ass I am like panicking
take a couple beers from the minibar I'm
drinking them in the car yeah going like
come on Burt you can do this recharge
you have to recharge and rehydrate I get
to the airport I look at this man and I
say I'm gonna leave all my bags with you
and get on this flight do you have a
card I can get from you to figure out
how to get my bags
this dude's the bet he goes I got it
gives me a card I go up and I go I'm
Bert Kreischer I fly all the time in
American I just want to get on this
flight they're like well hold it for I
literally you stood up like you're in an
a a meeting and introduce yourself I'm
Bert Kreischer I left everything I left
my backpack I left everything so that I
could I emptied out my pockets in the
car I grabbed my headsets and my phone
that's it and a charger
I literally barreled through security
rechecked
on my phone and went and they were shot
to pre-check they were shutting the door
and I was like I'm here hold on we got
one dude I got on there the guy how many
times a day do you announce your name
two people say get place lot that is one
of my flaws because you're Bert
Kreischer and you actively let the world
know this yeah do you must have insane
moments of people coming up to you
talking to you recognizing you thinking
that you know you guys have a close
intimate bond with each other yeah yeah
so how does that work out for like as a
32 year old woman when that happens for
me it's always a little like wonderful
and sweet and also like scary but for
someone like you I imagine people feel a
little bit safer just like bum-rushing
and like fully forcing themselves on
Hanah me drugs enemy and a Paul Koch
amen Wow I'm gonna pass man this is a
Dave & Buster's my kids are over there
oh yeah the 1099 meal plus gameplay so
like come on give me some space I had I
had a guy hammy pills on a flight one
time unmarked pills just in a little
baggie I saw you I saw your boarding the
machine and drops them on my table I'm
like oh yeah I'll totally three pills
don't tell me what they are on the
flight oh thanks brother I appreciate it
that's so nuts uh ya know I've had the
experience of where I've been like the
most hungover gone to an airport like
truly in a state of I just want to be
invisible to the world right now and
have like gone into the TSA booth like
hands up just fully succumbing to my own
terrible choices from the night before
and had someone go come on help me get
out of there and I'm like no not today
not right now not like this but you seem
to have a very healthy relationship with
your regret which I don't know if it
exists for you I don't have much regret
okay but you have some my regret is
honest I like I really I mean I don't
regret working for Travel Channel but I
regret I do regret not spending more
time at home with my family when they
were younger sure I was just working
trying to use that you know really those
are the problematic memories that
they're gonna hold for the rest of their
lives
yeah those fun years home I'm just doing
our specials trashing them like I had to
say last night at dinner I was like
alright ladies you know dad's coming out
we're special coming out right you two
daughters two daughters okay and here 10
to 12 for 200 so they're very formative
years of yeah this is yeah and I was
like dad's got a special coming out and
he talked I talk a lot about you guys
and they're like mom's already told us
but you didn't clear it with them before
you okay that's a healthy relationship I
had to say to my daughter last night my
young both my daughters got their
periods I had to say to my youngest the
other day last night I said hey just on
you know on Monday I'm doing Conan and
I'm thinking about talking about when
you got your period are you comfortable
with that she was like whoa she was like
wait tell me how you're gonna say it I
was like well you remember how you threw
yourself a period party and she was like
yeah
well not every girl does that no that's
very progressive beyond progressive it's
almost weird and I was liking so I
thought I was gonna attack thought I'd
tell that story mm-hmm she talked about
the red velvet cake she wanted a red
velvet cake I'm not even joking I'm not
I'm not enough of a woman compared to
your daughter he called me from school
was like I got my period
go to the store and get a red velvet
cake I'm like fact that she is changing
the shame game that is associated with
women bleeding from the inside a monthly
that's incredible yeah I was like oh
baby it's it's really cool I go and I
think I think it's something that I know
that my fans here at they think it's
funny and it's interesting and it's it
could be the future and I just think
it's a good support you can I steal this
for my own we hold this and you tell it
on stage but they okay so your daughters
are obviously you know they seem
supportive in what you do do you want
them to be in entertainment at all or is
this like a realm where it's like I've
experienced this so firsthand that I
would prefer for you guys to not have
this I don't want I I wouldn't mind I
mean they're obviously we're all know
there's a big a lot of jobs in
entertainment I think they both be
really good at like my oldest would be
great like PR or something okay but she
would not be not so much as a creative
type more like organization she might be
a good writer I just I don't know I
don't want either of them do what I do
really uh like it's too it's too much
yes to live by the sword die by the
sword like you have one screwed-up night
at work or you say something aired on
the podcast you're thinking about it at
dinner and you're like yeah and that
came out wrong where someone says
something to you in a comment that makes
your whole world turn upside down and
you can't see you like the light of day
yeah yeah I don't want them to ever
experience that I would love if they
just were like yeah I don't really give
a [ __ ] about that like I wouldn't like
I'm going into science yeah I just like
it's it's too much you know the thing I
had a buddy who got in a lot of trouble
he'd lied about something
and and he got called out big-big the
911 thing mm-hmm
yeah yeah my buddy and and he's in my
good friend and he's got kids and I went
to bed I put my kids together that night
and I went what if his what if his job
gets taken away from this like what if
his dreams get taken away yeah like
that's so weird that like you can say
something off-color that you don't mean
for it to hurting them you're just
talking [ __ ] impacts the entire text
your life and then your kid's life and
then all of a sudden like and I've done
that a lot I've said some that's what I
think it's so interesting about your as
someone that is a daughter to a dad
that's not a in the creative world but
someone that I love very much like I'm
always fascinated about like that
relationship that you have with them and
like is there a safe word that you guys
have of like don't talk about this or
like dad my friends know what you do and
I don't
it's embarrassing we're cool or like
gives them credit my daughter like
obviously I can't pregnant my daughter
my daughter one time she is a slime
thing you were saying that a nice line
account yeah which feels very 14 or 12
which one that's 12 12 okay friend have
a slime accounts like pretty much runs
it I just go in for gallop Lou doesn't
know to pop this line the way I do
that's amazing
yeah there's been there was one time
where there was something going on I
can't really share it all you know it
was really really funny and I and and I
said to my daughter you know I said
something to her and she and she said
the funniest thing back but it was about
something developmental in her life okay
and where is I guess all girls get
embarrassed of it like let's just
pretend it's getting hair on your legs
right okay and was shaving your like
something like that it's around that I
can imagine you can go from A to Z but
it's not as bad as you think he's just
real innocuous uh-huh and I was like you
know I shared something and she said
something hilarious and then I went oh
my god and she immediately goes you're
not talking about this on stage yeah I
mean my head I was like I was going to
share that on stage and I was going to
the Ice House I was like oh yeah but
like stuff like that safe boundaries
save boundary
my daughter has a crush on like I
wouldn't like that would be the worst
that would be the most embarrassing
that's what did this get feel Vaughn
just asked me if my daughter's had a
crush yet I was like yeah and he goes
what's his name and I was like I can't
say that's on their terms like that with
my wife
no there's nothing off limits really
yeah there's no limits what's crazy is
there's nothing off limits but then she
started a podcast and because nothing's
been off limits she dumped everything
she should all be like ridiculously on
this baby I got like I have years of it
built up let me do this I said where I
go I go hey hold on one second I go your
podcast fans come from my podcast like
those are the wives and the people
listen to my podcast I go you're
[ __ ] on me and then she goes hold on
one second who said that I farted on
their chin during oral sex and I was
like well you did and she goes and if
it's real it plays like all right you're
right right I can only imagine how
embarrassed you were right oh god I
can't believe I just called myself this
is such a fun game of like mental chess
that you guys are playing with each
other oh she likes you they were talking
about did you guys meet each other back
we had to meet in person before dating
apps can you believe that it's
disgusting I know
yeah that's dangerous just cause one
hard copy of the person they're like
that's what she looks like you can see
you can go maybe it's a bad angle
she's gorgeous then you meet her a
person you like all her butts a little
bigger than I'd like but I didn't get to
scroll through that I know she we I'd
seen her like three times I've seen her
face Runyon Canyon about that apartment
building she was like what a pervert
says about someone that they're stalking
okay we'll take it works
I'm sorry yoga class break up with her
boyfriend
are you happening upon these moments or
are you following her to these
destinations are we had mutual friends
are my room that doesn't answer my
question dated her girl her best friend
and her writing partner and so okay and
by the way if we're gonna be really
honest he had kind of stalked her so so
it might have been like I might add
offense third wheel stalking you know
yeah this is a fun soup to get involved
in right now
and then and then we all do all the big
group of us now all people that I know
all went bowling one night okay I was
good finally a safe activity I was hot
I was oh I'll show you a picture of what
I looked like in you this is why we're
filming the podcast now because of these
visual moments for everyone you shine I
bet you go I bet you go that's not you
okay I'm I'm going over my lines in my
head this is are you google image
searching yourself yeah because if I
wait it comes how famous you are that
you don't have these photos and you're
like photo album you have to Google
Image Search yourself to pull up old
photos you ready yeah that's not you
awesome Melissa just goes whoa like a
Joey Lawrence full my wife well sorry
but like I was joking
cheesy posing for the record like I
didn't really think I look like that but
the are the sunglasses in the necklace
is specific to this necklace is real
real but that well you were in like
grade school when I took this picture
enough to know that those sunglasses are
not okay these were cool okay sure they
protected your eyes from the UV rays at
the Sun yeah projects I get it the guy
that had come
that's your wife met that person my wife
met that person and bowling bowling and
then she was like told my roommate
mm-hmm hey your roommates cool cute
he'll be sure you saw me and my ex break
up so he's very sensitive
the day she broke up with her ex I had
done yoga next to her and I sweat
aggressively as you can tell I just swam
a sweater like I'm cool with it but in
yoga I was pouring sweat so bad it was
puddling and she was laughing
hysterically and she's like are you okay
I was like I was talking I was burbling
because sweats pouring in through my
mouth and I'm like oh I'm flying and she
and she was like I think he's cute and
then told my roommate tell him to ask me
out and this is by the way this is gonna
be a part of it there's a part of me
that I share with people and they never
believe like I have real I've only had
sex with six people women I don't know
why some people with six women women
okay you had you felt the need to catch
yourself you believe it way no I guess
nothing wrong with that anymore but I
was in
when I grew up you could you say people
get home and so I'm not like a big I'm
not good with chicks I've never yeah
obviously more concerned about like the
partner got it I'm or somewhere the
partner yeah I wanted to fall in love
and so this was and when she called up
it was like hey how come he roommate
hasn't asked me out I was like oh she's
a [ __ ] I can't go out with her and then
you buy from a distance put this woman
through the wringer before even going on
a first date with her you watched her be
to break up with her ex you sweat like a
lunatic in front of her and then yeah
preemptively push sexually evasive oh
yeah and then we went out on a date I
was like is she just perfect like you
know when you meet someone in your life
that's a nice button up on that yeah she
was just everything that you want and
like she dumped me like after four
months I couldn't like she said she had
said I love you to me and I couldn't say
it back so I was just I've been burned
you have been literally following this
woman for months and you couldn't say
back in love with her but I couldn't and
she was like well then if you can't say
it it's over
uh-huh dumped me and immediately I was
like I gotta get her back I gotta get
her back oh no I made a mixtape I made I
did my god cried in my car on the brand
Franklin crying you were crying your car
driving every day of my life that
happens a lot more than you'd expect in
LA okay wait what was on the mixtape a
lot of Coldplay and he's got the
greatest relationship of all time yeah
right yeah I really knew how to speak my
language yeah I mean they consciously
uncoupled really really progressive yeah
and then I and this she came back to me
and so how long have you guys been
together now 15 years
no well being together we've been I
think we've been together like 16 17
years okay 15 years married and now she
finally gets like her voice in like your
relationship out like in the creative
world oh yeah yeah are you ever worried
that there's a lot I mean there's
chapters to your relationship from what
it sounds like that are gonna get aired
that you're nervous about it all being
aired I'm see that's the problem
I'm super honest but you're an open book
yeah like like it's like hi guys I say I
say way too much Lincoln and I because
part of me goes whe off
we all think the same things yeah I can
I'm not better than anyone I'm not worse
than anyone and so like and so yeah I
don't I'm pretty honest I've never hit
her I've never cheated on her I never
hit my kids I've never I've never raised
my voice like in the manner but that's
just not me like I'm not alike a like I
raised my voice but I'm like what you
went into a realm that that wasn't even
consider yeah Mike did you [ __ ] on her
chest if it's gonna come up in a pocket
no I wish I wish my wife would the
things that she would share about me is
like I'd like I'll throw it like I'll
throw a temper tantrum if we have sex
like I'll be like like I'll turn into a
baby okay Patti okay
I've been a little sick lately so she
said and but I just got home off the
road no one have sex
and said I'm not getting sick it was her
birthday she's good I'm not getting sick
on my birthday for you that's self-care
yeah and I was like I don't sleep I do
it for you and she's like literally I'm
not even joking and I keep saying or
like hey come in bed I just want to talk
to you for a little bit she's like it's
not happening it's not happening that's
a trap yeah that's a trap yeah exactly
and then today I was getting out of the
shower to get ready to do press and she
said she is cleaning my side of the
closet because I just have not done it
and she said babe I am truly sorry we
haven't gotten take to take care of your
needs but I hope you do understand that
I just don't want to get the flu again
this year and even still I was like okay
but tonight right one that is the most
like textbook from a therapist opinion
way to present your feelings to a
significant other yes it's the most
clear concise real honest thing that she
can probably say to you yeah and the
most rational calm way to say it to you
and still does not fully resonate she
has shared the worst fights we've ever
had on her podcast I mean there's some
therapeutic element oh there is oh dude
what she got me in therapy she was like
you need every I was getting PTSD from
doing Travel Channel so I was doing
dangerous stuff every week yeah it was
just getting worse yeah building up and
so everything turned into
a 90-foot scuba dive everything turned
into a bungee jump yeah everything like
the littlest things and I would just and
I would melt down the way I would in the
shower in New Zeeland before I did a 500
foot rope swing
yeah just full panic attacks out of
nowhere and I couldn't I couldn't I
couldn't measure what was real and what
wasn't real you can't navigate that yeah
it's all right when your brain is had
that much like trauma put on it like to
actually honestly compartmentalize like
what's happening to you in this present
moment I'm sure it was extremely
stressful but and so she got me into
therapy and I know the best thing that
ever happened to me
sweet well on that really I don't know
we're going to take a quick break right
back but Burke create create sure the
worst you say it the better my fans like
cry share is hell yeah which is
basically a Cher's Twitter account we'll
be right back with more not too deep
right after this using thousands of real
women's measurements third love designs
its bras with breast size and shape in
minds that they fit impeccably and feel
even better that's right today's episode
is sponsored by third love and now since
adding 24 new sizes third love offers
the most options of any brand I'm
talking a total of 70 sizes so you can
find your fit in 60 seconds online order
and try on at home with there at loves
fit finder quiz it's actually fun and
takes less than a minute and there's no
more awkward fitting room experiences so
it's hands-down the most comfortable bra
that you will ever own from premium
ultra soft smoothing fabrics to expert
design features like straps that don't
slip the details make the difference and
the labels are even tagless so they're
not itchy and because third love
guarantees a perfect fit returns and
exchanges are free and easy and you are
talking to a sports bra loving woman
through and through and I will tell you
that third loves bras are infinitely
more comfortable than my own dirty
sports bras I am a changed woman they
sent me a few of their designs and it's
absolutely fantastic could not recommend
more so excited to every time they
sponsor the podcast third love know
there's a perfect bra for everyone so
right now they're offering you guys the
listeners 15% off your first order go to
third love comm / grace now to find your
perfect fitting bra and get 15% off your
first purchase
that's third love.com / grace for 15%
off today we're back with Bert Kreischer
so okay I have your whole demeanor from
what I've observed on social media and
observed from you directly is pretty
positive it's pretty just like
fun-loving good time do you have a
nemesis mmm-hmm or what's your biggest
like pet peeve on like a human level
I mean honestly my biggest pet peeves
hypocrisy mmm that was what drives me
nuts his hypocrisy I get that yeah I try
not to be hypocritical but I also and I
try mm-hmm and I call myself out when I
do it sure and my I see my fans but
people this in my podcast have called me
out a ton yeah what's your prime
audience is it mostly dudes dudes your
own age or you 18 to 45 yeah and they're
all have trying to work on their beards
oh they like to get buzz they're looking
to fall in love they're just regular oh
that's I mean I think that's like a
really fun new kind of like personality
type to really uh sure in it's like I
think the idea of party animal gets you
know kind of lumped in with
chauvinistic or whatever like people
that aren't in touch with their emotions
and I think you represent something
that's a little bit more in touch with
your emotions definitely I'm not I'm not
showing it as a weakness yeah I think
yeah I mean I think there's a lot of
guys like me who have like low
self-esteem but like to have a good time
yeah and their friends make jokes about
them and they're like like they can roll
with it and then they're just really
good guys and I think that's the
majority of my fan base and and but
they're pretty honest they're pretty
real and then I always said this and
I've said this to other people the
format of podcasting I mean I've been in
it for a while yeah just in my 300th
episode the format of podcasting is a
conversation with my fans so when I do
say something [ __ ] up or something
that maybe I misspeak my friends will
call me on it and start
conversation with me either in my DMS or
just online you mean like an honest
respectful dialogue about something yeah
instead of shaming you for not knowing a
different way yeah and I think that is
an extension of Rogan Romans fans were
like like you know this is a we're just
this like a safe place we're all just
hanging out and we're having a
conversation and if we say something
really horrible realize that we're high
and we're just screwing around and call
us on it mulch and will help me change
my opinion yeah yeah I said on stage all
the time listen to my every joke that
you don't like so cool come up to me and
talk to me share with me tell me why you
don't like it like there was a joke I
had about getting a [ __ ] for my wife
one time and this girl came up and goes
just you know that is really aggressive
and I had never I was a joke to me it
wasn't real and so I was like yeah that
is pretty aggressive and I just have
instructive criticism it's like the
reason why people talk about rape jokes
I don't tell rape jokes only because
like I don't this personal by the way I
can laugh at them I can laugh at her
whatever you want to talk about but like
just personally it would really bum me
out
if I ruin someone's night if they did
like got a sitter care gotten dressed
putting on makeup came out to my show
with their husband laughing along and
then all the sudden I just brought up
the worst thing that ever happened in
our life let's just go home do that yeah
well that's really considerate which I
think makes you more of a selfless
performer than a lot of people or you're
really doing it for your audience
well yeah I'm doing it for myself cuz I
just don't want to be sitting there like
like I had this really great joke about
black chicks once that I thought was
just brilliant okay and and and it was
getting laughs but there's two black
chicks came up to me in DC and they're
like hey man huge fans I think you need
to stop telling like Joe's like are you
serious and they're like it's just a
little [ __ ] up it's and the I think
the wrong people are laughing and you're
like really and they're like yeah we get
it I don't think you're a bad person
when there's nothing bad you're saying
in it but there's a line in there that I
think the wrong people are laughing at I
know it's so interesting yeah and you're
like oh yeah yeah that you're like you
don't want to accidentally encourage
someone that doesn't fully understand
where you're coming from and it wasn't a
negative joke it was just one line it
was one line one line always it's one
line like I had a joke I did joke about
this black
one time and these both have to do with
race I don't I mean they just write it
randomly but I just joke about this
black guy one time about um me and him
around a bar I stop telling the joke but
me I'll tell you why okay and it's an
innocuous joke sure me and him go to bar
Middle Eastern guy walks in orders a
beer leaves and the black guy said I'm
shortening it the black guy says man I
hope that [ __ ] not on my plane
and I and we're at an airport bar and I
go me too
to him just to be nice and then I went
oh wait I'm being racist I'm being
racist to him like wait how far have we
come as a people when a black man and a
white man commit a hate crime together
and then I was like yes we can and and
then the joke was wait he said it to a
white guy if he thinks I'm racist about
Middle Eastern guys he must think I'm
racist across the board like oh my god
and then I'm like I'm implicating myself
and then I was like and then the line
was hey how does he know my racism stops
at Middle Eastern people but then white
people were coming up going yeah mine
doesn't stop at Middle Eastern people
either I was like stepping in it
scenario okay but so you just go alright
I'll just put that joke on the show and
one day if it comes up I can figure it
out I'll figure it out but today's not
today today is not the day on a
different note physically you ran a
marathon yeah when it's like three
months ago four months ago how no
friends my house as I sweat in a room
doing a podcast I say it's the Mickey
Mantle gene I just decided to do it so
it's like it's the yeah the mental
capacity of like believing that you can
that a little bit of physical
superiority over the average person I'm
predisposed for athleticism
I believe Mickey Mantle was a great
athlete he he could party all night long
with Billy Martin show up at the field
at 6:00 in the morning and play a game
and hit two home runs about balance and
it's just about those guys that just
refused to let a little bit of a
hangover affect them so I didn't play
the most inspirational thing anyone's
ever said on this bond yes I appreciate
it so much I didn't train for it at all
I just didn't train
a marathon at all at all you know people
that train like [ __ ] their pants
actively running a marathon yeah what
happened on Sepulveda and San Vicente I
watched a woman a grown woman like an
executive [ __ ] her pants and I went
that's why you train my legs seized up
and I was like oh my god no I just I
told my buddies I could probably run a
marathon no training and they're like oh
you can't no you can't you can't run a
marathon and I was like I definitely
could I definitely good okay we would
never thought about this before in your
life until this year it was until I was
it was me
Segura and Ari and Joe and we were on a
podcast and I was like I definitely run
a marathon so now you're socially
accountable for doing it once you put it
out there and they're like you can't do
it I was like I could do it and I and
always like my dad did it he had to
Train forever I was like your dad's 80
of course I could definitely beat your
dad he's like you couldn't beat my dad
this boils down to a different like
issue and so I just I just I went out
party the night before showed up to the
LA Marathon I was out there bragging
just like people go there's no better
feeling than crossing the finish line of
the marathon and going at all that
training paid off you know the better
feeling is crossing the finish and go
and look at the people go I didn't even
train for this that's the alternative
Nike slogan is I didn't even train for
this just did it I just did it don't try
just do this I mean your body had to be
physically like rocked so what was the
recovery like did you [ __ ] your pants
behind closed doors
I did not [ __ ] my pants 20 mm-hmm which
is probably like the worst most
excruciating moment 20 mile 22 my calves
seized up the woman in front of me [ __ ]
her pants and I watch people drop off
like zombies and I was like oh my god I
don't know if I really don't care now I
don't know if I'm gonna finish yeah and
so I just said to myself if I need to
walk hour walk so I started walking a
little bit it had a five hour pace at
that time Wow and and it took me an
extra thirty minutes those last like six
miles it took me an extra thirty minutes
I had to walk if I needed to walk but
yeah you ran six miles in 30 minutes
no no I ran six miles in like an hour
okay I'm just I was like six miles in 30
minutes is not walking no no okay but
then and then people and then the here's
the problem is I couldn't walk for a
week all that that braggadocious
behavior of like I didn't even train for
this
yeah okay could an exercise for like
well over a month gained 15 pounds
immediately yeah that's a marathon
trained like people that run marathons
obviously gained 15 pounds after the
marathon after yeah a lot of guys can
fit a lot of guys can't work out after a
marathon but if you don't train for it
you really can't yeah I'm shocked that
you walked up the steps to get into this
apartment today I just ran a triathlon
like two two weeks ago what why someone
said I couldn't sew you up you're fueled
by spite it's what it sounds like
everything is done by Spike we did we
meet Joe Howe Joe our and Tom Joe Rogan
Ari Shaffir and Tom Segura did a podcast
they asked me how much in this podcast
ask me how much I drank and I made the
tag like like your doctor your answered
honestly to them I entered I am well
first my answer honestly to my doctor
excited he's gonna tell me if I need to
stop but I answered honestly to them and
I told them how much I drank and they
were the Lord they were like like Andre
the Giant level of drinking I guess to
them okay so they were like they were
like whoa and they were like we should
do sober October we're in October uh-huh
we would not drink any drugs and so so I
didn't and I was like I could do that
and they're like they can't and I was
like no I definitely can and then look
you need to see a doctor
you're gonna have stroke you're gonna
have the DTS and I was like I'm gonna be
fine I I don't drink all the time like
there's often do I just not great okay
so I tell my therapist I was like I'm
gonna do it he was like I think that's
great and he's like what's your
motivation and I literally said spike I
wanna show them that I can do it and so
I could drinking for a month I didn't
have your own personal health for your
own personal well-being
I started you know
member first the second the first day we
could a midnight I started drinking
again harder than I ever had nose like
told you I could do it
Wow okay so what's the next phenomenal
feat that you're going to put your body
through I don't know he's waiting for
someone to challenge you to something
there's a couple bets on the on the
table okay table right now there's a few
bets on the table okay and so uh you
don't to put you don't the I haven't
accepted them because its first of all
it's a lot of money and like yeah six
figures
yikes and so and it's a it's tough and
it would be a lot it would be a genuine
lifestyle change do this it's just and
so and it's hard to make lifestyle
changes when you're the motivating
factor is spiked yeah it's not money by
the way it's not money yes not losing
money or winning the money I could give
two shits about that it's it's spiked
yeah I don't know that that actually
will create a lifestyle change I do yeah
we'll see okay well I'm very excited to
see um I wanted to talk to you a little
bit about like you've a new Netflix
special that's coming out and that whole
world to me is fascinating stand-up
terrifies me I am so scared of it I
exist behind like a Wi-Fi passcode
scenario so going out just like speaking
directly and looking in faces of people
and telling jokes and hoping they accept
them as nuts what was it like creating
this special this time around it was
really fun yeah yeah it was really fun
but you know I I really enjoyed I really
enjoyed getting ready for a special yeah
yeah I love okay that seems like the
most intense time to me it's very
intense yeah I don't know if I'm I don't
know what the word is I that I am a
crazy compulsive or obsessive obsessive
compulsive but or like or like
passionate passionate I'm very impulsive
okay so my favorite thing about stand-up
my favorite thing is writing I love
writing I love when you're at the very
beginning like the salad days of an hour
and you're just going onstage coming up
with that idea like you have an idea
like I had an idea the other day I've
had the funniest thing I haven't written
the joke yet but I I just write in the
beginning part is I I came home really
high from the store one night
really really high like kind of higher
you're like I can't go to bed yet I'm
gonna forget how to breathe amazing that
you got home uber my uber
/ Laurel Canyon in the back of a car
that I think had a bucket seat and he
was playing Perry Farrell's satellite of
love cover and I thought I was in a
starship oh my god I get home and that
and I'm like I'm so high I'm walking
around my house going like good still
singing satellites gone way up to Mars
I walk in my kitchen and my dog is I
have 140 pound bull mastiff my dog is
putting away the silverware she's got
one elbow on the counter and a paw in
the silverware drawer
and she looks at me like are you gonna
help and I start laughing hysterically
and immediately I go this has got to be
a joke what's happening and so I start
walking over to her and I realize she's
eating a cake on the counter she's using
the drawer stability but it was like the
cakes I mean hurry okay and she looks at
me she gives me eyes when I took my
leman to get a bite of the cake and she
looks at me like what we're doing this
it was almost like you'd imagine a
husband the look he'd give his wife but
she's like it's your birthday let's have
a friend so and so in real life that's
it that's I mean in real life I walked
already cake she my wife walked inside
what the [ __ ] you doing and don't blame
it on me she was putting away silverware
I was like my favorite when something
like that happens you go to your phone
you put it your phone you write in your
book and then you're like all right
let's take it up onstage you don't know
where it's going and then you just start
talking about it and we love that I love
that that's is that in your special no
that's not that's new that happened last
Tuesday
oh that's so good you don't really
change any of it very well but then so
then with this special you write all
this stuff you know all this stuff and
then you have it all in your head you've
got some old stuff like like the
interaction I have at the bar with the
black guy and so you got all this old
stuff that hasn't worked in the past but
you got it there so if you need to dip
in or pull a part of that out you can
plug it in and then and then you get an
offer from Netflix and they're like you
want to do a special yeah and you by the
way you've you've been hitting your
agents up I'm ready I'm ready
yeah cuz I got I got an hour thirty yeah
let me know you're ready and when once I
tell you ready you get like three months
and in that three months I did stand-up
maybe a hundred I did that one hour a
hundred fifty times Wow I just work
shopping in just I get up every night I
get up every single night I get up I'd
go Tuesdays and Wednesdays on the road I
do two shows - one-nighters and
different clubs I then do a weekend
Thursday Friday Saturday I bang out a
Sunday in a closed city where I could
probably only do one show I fly them
home Monday I do spots at the store
Monday but you just become obsessive and
you do that hour and you find chunks
that work together and then you're like
alright I got these couple chunks it
feels like a puzzle right oh it's
amazing it's it's so much fun to take
your one chunk and then go and then
literally at the last minute at the very
last minute you're in the room and and
and you're like and someone goes someone
one of the execs is like that line you
say comes off a little racist and you by
the way no one's ever noticed it yeah no
one's ever noticed it you're like really
and then I'm just saying it's just in
this day and age just can you change the
line you're like I'm about to do this
right now and you're like I just think I
just think would be best interest to
just change the one line by the way the
lines innocuous innocuous trust when I
say it is overthinking executive and
things that give you a note for the sake
of their job thinking that in a lot of
trouble right there yeah that means my
best friend yeah and then my wife just
changes the line to Pikachu
and everyone laughs and you go out and
you're like I'm getting chill bumps
right now the first time I said that I
lines Pikachu I just though all the word
is Pikachu okay so what's the special
they're gonna fake it see this moment
Pikachu and my wife just said
wife said mom was an idiot she just went
what about Pikachu and everyone laughed
in the room and I went Pikachu and
they're like I think it works and then
you go out in the room and all you I'm
getting chill bumps don't even I'm you
joking you got the room you get to that
part of the thing and then you're like
we gotta wait for Pikachu here and the
whole place goes nuts and you look off
in your wife's with your agent and your
best friend that you grew up with who's
producing the special Tony Hernandez and
they're dying laughing like we did it in
your head you're like oh that's what all
this working than the one [ __ ] line
that's an incredibly sweet story yeah it
was really uh and so and but that make
I'm sure like you do a lot of stand-up
but like those are the moments that make
it personal for you and make it feel
like a true accomplishment yeah and and
and you know I was very cognizant of the
way people take in specials these days
yeah I mean it's the world that you guys
operate in and I learn a lot from Brooks
is like it's nuts I mean the YouTube
space has changed dramatically every day
and every year but the stand-up space
which has been so traditional for so
long is changing so much now that I feel
like you guys are all kind of like
navigating it trying to figure it out
it's you learn a lot the more you do it
mhm and and and like one of the things
that you that one of the things I was
very aware of is why I was turning off
specials mmm like I watched his special
at this guy and he was talking about the
city they were in for 15 minutes if you
know that special you know what special
I'm talking about I'm not gonna say it
but a part of me I was like I was like
man I really care what city you're in I
did a lot and I was and I don't really
don't care what city you're in
yeah tell me a joke and then I watched
Jim Jeffries special I talked to Jim
about this mm-hmm
and I was like man you killed me you're
special you walked on stage you didn't
say a word you went Bill Cosby and the
place went nuts
and I was like I'm in I'm dying to hear
what you have to say and then I thought
then you start thinking oh I got to tell
a joke I gotta get out there and tell a
joke and my laugh per minutes better be
up and then Netflix is like everyone
turns off at 30 minutes and you're like
all right let me just move my closer up
to 28 minutes let's see what happens if
I move my closer to 28 minutes you feel
it in the room and it murders and you're
like okay now I got a really I gonna
move something to the back end to carry
that next 20 minute next 28 minutes it
really it's such a fun process
I'm excited for my next one because I've
already got like I've got 52 minutes of
new material really already after this
that's nice
yeah period party did we talk about that
period parties I'm telling you that's
the name of your next special I wish I
got this joke about Starbucks that is my
best joke I've ever written in my life
ever just tease people with it don't
tell us the joke don't we sit here yes
damn it come see me live Sam live okay
we're you take one more quick break and
then we're gonna get into the Twitter
questions really quickly with Bert and I
mean obviously by this time you should
watch this special I feel personally
invested in the whole narrative of it
get you if we're not sponsored by
Pokemon this episode sport for today's
show comes from our good buddies at
Casper we love Casper Casper is the
sleep brand that continues to
revolutionize its line of products to
create an exceptionally comfortable
sleep experience one night at a time
they have three mattress models they
have the original Casper the wave and
the essential Casper mattresses are
perfectly designed to soothe and cradle
your natural geometry not to mention the
breathable design helps you sleep cool
and regulates your body temperature
throughout the night and it's delivered
right to your door in one of those small
how did they do that size box with free
shipping and returns in the US and
Canada but the best part is that you can
be sure of your purchase with Casper's
100 night risk-free sleep on a trial
that's three months it's over 300 very
much at least three months after all you
spend one third of your life sleeping so
you should be comfortable in let me tell
you guys these beds are comfortable I
slept on my Casper mattress last night
so comfortable they really are like the
one that I have is probably the most
comfortable bed I've ever I've ever
owned ya know same as an adult buying a
mattress I didn't realize was incredibly
expensive and also very difficult to do
and so Casper when it showed up at my
door I thought I was being punked yeah
because it's a tiny little box it's a
tiny box and then you undo the box and
you cut the plastic off and then it
yes like presents itself beautiful
mattress in front of you it slowly
inflates on its own it's beautiful
pretty red and you guys can get fifty
dollars towards select mattresses by
visiting Casper comm slash Grace and
using grace at checkout that's Casper
comm such grace offer code grace for $50
off your mattress purchase terms and
conditions apply support for today's
show comes from Rafi's Ralphie's shoes
are stylish sustainable and comfortable
enough for everyday wear anywhere and I
can speak to this on a personal level I
got a pair of mustard-colored
cute adorable flats that make me feel
sleek stylish and like I am just an
overall capable human being Rafi's is
the everyday flat for life on the go
with three fashionable styles the flat
the point and the loafer for women and
girls and an amazing color and pattern
selection that's always getting updated
not to mention they're the softest shoe
that you will put on your foot seriously
you won't believe that they're made from
recycled plastic water bottles you heard
me we recycled plastic water bottles and
a major added bonus they're machine
washable because let's face it feet are
gross they do things they sweat they
create dirt and gross 'no sin that area
and you know what now you can clean your
shoes I love Rafi's and I know you will
too right now Rafi's has an amazing deal
for you my beautiful listeners use code
grace grac e to get free shipping no
minimum that's free shipping and free
returns and exchanges on your Rafi shoe
when you go to Rafi's ro th YS comm
enter grace grac e it's a no brainer
shoes that are comfortable stylish and
sustainable plus free shipping get
yourself a pair today Rafi's comm promo
code grace get this deal while it lasts
we're back to bird this is very exciting
I'm gonna ask you some Twitter questions
now but before we do I'm going to ask
you the two questions I ask every single
guest that's on the podcast and the
first one is who alive or dead would you
most want to throw cold spaghetti at
throw cold spaghetti mm-hmm
Wow oh yeah it's pretty it's you know
very hard-hitting journalism type
question alive or dead who would I want
to throw cold spaghetti at mm hmm I
don't have to say Sodom Hussein okay I
don't think we've ever gotten that
answer son Hussein had a lot to do with
my life because that's a sentence I when
I was in high school he was the first
war oh yeah and I got to experience hmm
and so I remember coming in and going
like and going look I'm not I'm not for
war I'm against warm protesting the war
my dad goes my dad literally said you're
a [ __ ] idiot go to your room until
you realize why you're a [ __ ] idiot
and then I sat in my room and I was like
I don't know why and then I walked
downstairs my dad explained to me who
Sodom Hussein was and why we're going to
war and that he was killing his own
people
and he said you have no idea this is the
first time in life we can watch a war on
TV this is ground breaking you need to
be for this war and for what's happening
right now because what we're doing is a
good thing we were helping his people
get out of his oppression and we're
watching it on TV and swimming in my dad
sat and watched the war and I was like
oh and then I remember the second war
and I was like ah before this works my
dad said so and everyone's like you're a
[ __ ] idiot you got to figure out why
you're an idiot
and then I watched Sodom Hussein get
killed I feel like I followed that guy's
career it's quite a quite a fanboy well
you went out like a gangster you got to
admit that walk to the gallows didn't
say a word
do you know if they walk me to the
gallows like they did thought I must I
can imagine that you would not be quiet
that's the greatest last words perfect
well yeah I would love to see the moment
that you get to throw a cold spaghetti
yet um I'm actually so curious to know
your answer for this question I asked
every single guest to tell us their
worst pants shooting story or like close
call but you can only use three words or
three small phrases so for instance mine
is college jogging front lawn I love
that mm-hmm I feel like you might have
multiple scenarios in which this applies
but I'm curious
- no the worst one the worst one tennis
camp ok all over the stall stolen men's
clothes well no follow-up questions it
really paints a picture I want to see if
I can do this with a bunch of them hold
on give me a couple more okay this is a
weird game of charades 6 a.m.
MacDougal Street uh-huh sister says oh
the family was involved a sister like
New York is the appropriate place for
that to happen I feel like it happens
more times than we care to admit in that
city that's by the refrigerator
he doesn't wear underwear we'll be back
Barnes & Noble Black Friday boys and
opal Banana Republic Oh God a chic
Banana Republic don't do it they're all
those perfect but that's a fun [ __ ]
game it's really fun the only times it's
not fun is when you ask someone and they
don't have an immediate memory but
they've repressed deep down like
emotionally in their lives
yeah so that's like it's kind of a it's
a tell for people to understand like I
really truly connect with you because
you have multiple stories immediately
come to so many I had one time where we
were on Travel Channel the world's
biggest what's those what's those
crystals
you know when they cut something in half
yeah it's it was at the world's biggest
geode and I had walked my two travellers
down the stairs to show them now by the
way okay
secret time I'm obsessed with geodes
I've been obsessed with geode since I
was a kid and I told them I was obsessed
with geodes I've been obsessed with
geodes
a lot of energy from geodes I love
geodes I love Jesus and I walk down sit
down down this all this this steps its
out on the world's biggest geode is on
an island off of Ohio in the in the
middle one of the Great Lakes okay I was
gonna say Ohio's landlocked I don't
understand
just off Cedar Point okay and we get
down to the bottom and the cameras are
rolling and I see the geode and I go oh
my god and I [ __ ] my pants and I but
it's in a very small area and everyone
starts gagging I don't have another pair
of pants and my camera crew and I had
already told them I was like I get
really excited for geodes and they're
like you weren't kidding you [ __ ] your
pants like that really does bra energy
either exist that we think people can go
like pop video and actively watch it and
know this moment every story I tell us a
hundred percent true and that one is two
hundred percent true Crystal Cave is it
crystal cable I'm looking up now as the
world's largest geode it's on in Ohio
yep it's it's gotta be it
earth can't wait where is this it's a
small island that we took a boat to yeah
no this looks nuts yeah yeah off of Lake
Erie yeah yeah whoa cool I mean I get
[ __ ] your pants for this geode if I
stick my pants so bad oh my god Travel
Channel Wow well thank you for the
whirlwind of stories surrounded by that
I feel like this is your new podcast I
could that's a genius that's a genius
bit well it's just I think the great
equalizer for all of us so as adults we
still can't control every aspect of our
bodies which I think brings us together
okay let's get into these Twitter
questions I'm really interested in what
people want to know about you know
someone and this was curious to me
everyone's asking is he still the
Machine and your Twitter bio is very
funny it's I am a party animal comedian
actor author host has
passenger fast eater glutton husband dad
dad is last so curious order that but
then I am the machine yep so people
still want to know are you still the
machine yeah I'm definitely still the
machine I mean your body has been put
through the test oh I am definitely
still the machine what do you do to
relax we can answer this later we can
take it offline honestly I think to
relax I I like to I do like to work out
I know that sounds crazy if you don't
think I work out but I like to work out
I like to hike and then I like to get my
pool and then there's nothing getting in
my pool having a double Cheetos and soda
in a cigar and then the girls coming out
and then like dad what are we grilling
tonight that I get so [ __ ] excited
for that that's so you're just like Al
Bundy with a little bit more money that
you have a pool I'm totally I am so what
they think the American male is in that
intelligent zone yeah we were like bro I
get I'm just smart enough for Hollywood
where I'm like hey Bruce Willis is dead
I don't get it
when did he die Oh Donnie Wahlberg shot
in oh my god he's been a ghost hold on
like I'm that smart Oh throw on the TV I
got an outdoor TV throwing like what
yeah yeah oh you watched golf I loved
watching I'm obsessed with Tiger Woods
as a person that exists in pop culture
as a golfer golfer I believe really I
believe in him I mean he is I don't find
golf interesting no offense yeah I think
because I just don't see I see skill on
some level but I don't see a athleticism
which is you could argue that you're
right about you I don't think anyone
that wears belts as an athlete and it's
the dumbest thing I've ever seen I don't
think they know like I don't think
they're cognizant that they're wearing
belts that whole goddamn game oh you're
cognizant when you slide in headfirst
yeah but that happened every five
minutes in baseball I would love it you
don't like or no baseball game I'm
impatient as [ __ ] I want to see
immediate results I like to see
lettuces weather support them what's
happy to be I want theater named the the
sport that is based on belts oh yeah but
those belts if you're gonna wear a belt
I want it aggressive oversized I want to
see my reflection in it it's great that
I mean that's literally like going to
medieval times in my mind like it's oh
my god how many have you been to five
wait I've got one in Orlando we've and
we've gone I've gone to Jersey and out
here I haven't gone to Toronto I haven't
gone to our land oh I've got five times
I went from my birthday we went for my
daughter's birthday we went for my
wife's birthday like it is the best and
by the way I don't like when you go and
it's packed I've been when it's not
packed a week when it's sad oh they
still got to do it I've gone when the
hawk that's supposed to I've gone the
hawk stays in the rafters the decides it
doesn't want to come down and the guy
that rankles the hawk has to sit there
and go oh no and then he just waves his
rope at it for like ten minutes
that's sad times this last time you went
the hawk goes through the thing I'm
wasted right it is it is early on a
Sunday early on a Saturday it's my
daughter eyelas birthday that's an
appropriate dad I've got an entire bus I
rented a tour bus to take all her
friends down
me and my wife that's it no one but Isla
says I want to sit I wanna sit by you
dad and I'm like okay so all her friends
are there it's a blast I'm buzzed and
the hawk comes out and Isla is just like
me and she goes we need a bird of prey
and all I can think is can you imagine
how cool it would be to take it out to a
park and be like go it just does a loop
it comes back skims everyone's heads let
them know like me it could really hurt
you
god I would love an owl big boy from
Outkast all he has is like nine owl just
got Al's all in this place and I'm
obsessed with them and I and I he I met
him and we follows me on Instagram and I
want to be like man how do I get it out
there is illegal I don't know how he's
doing it Google it's not a Google
you're matters you got a license to
rescue owls in order to have out I think
he's rescuing owls which is ultimately
and very noble and nice and so not
hip-hop like I've been rescuing owls I
respect it though at what a trump card
I'm so glad you love medieval times of
medieval times I lost my passport at
medieval times the most recent time I
went that's how much fun I had but then
that's Brooks lost a bet and my win was
to take him to medieval times for the
first time as an adult and he had no
idea what he had signed up for but then
lost his mind in the arena because it's
like walking into a casino there's no
windows you're just there it's daylight
outside still but you lose your minds in
the safe comfortable zone I owe my I
want to say my maybe let's say 36th
birthday 35th birthday I had a daughter
I two daughters at the time George it
was maybe like three or four right and
they do the whole thing and the prince
who wins gets to discern determine the
queen of princess of love and beauty yep
and he's making a big thing about it and
it's it's a dead night it's like a
Tuesday night so it's slow right and he
looks at me and he takes his glance and
he takes a rose and he puts it to me and
I'm like oh my god I'm the princess of
love and beauty and I take the rose and
my wife goes hey [ __ ] that's meant
for your daughter and Georgia had been
reaching out with me and he was like got
the princes like no to the right to the
road I'm like oh yeah why would I be
princess elbow table music are you
Georgia and then George is like for me
and I was like that I said I love that
was your like Bachelorette moment of
like I will accept this fair I've never
gotten a rose and I enjoy screaming at
the children that often times get the
roses and this partially probably why I
don't get the Rose I've also been with
friends where they've heckled the other
nights so hard that the nights literally
have screamed from their horses it's
make-believe bro where they've been like
[ __ ] you Green Knight you saw the dick
and then the guy has to be like it's
make-believe your ponytail
yeah really got into his psyche and just
fully scrambled it I love when they get
a horse that's a little out of control
and you see their horsemanship I like
that so I'm like I get where this horse
is this works having a bad day and it
still has to work yeah like just foaming
at the mouth it's the best time it's a
little too expensive I wish it was a
little bit more cost-effective 15 kids
also I went once for a friend's 30th
birthday and it was like 10 of us and
then we're like drunk by the end of it
being like let's get you know tequila
shots for everyone like as the end of
the night thing and they started pouring
shots and then we're like wait a minute
how much is it they're like it's $15 a
shot we're like put it back in the
bottle put it back we don't think yeah I
can't we very much appreciate rusty but
like we can't do I'm not gonna pay for
that biscuits this is by the way as you
said that I went oh my god daughter's
12th birthday we all go this past 1:00
we get done and my daughter has the same
impulse brain I have okay everyone's
going to the bathroom the Bynes for the
bathrooms long and I looks at me he goes
we could buy a sword and I'm like and
then you in your head you're like yeah I
got money I buy whatever the [ __ ] I was
and I go I go how much are the swords
he's like he's like a hundred bucks and
I was like I go which one do you want
it's a steal she's like for me and I go
it's your birthday which one she goes I
want that dagger oh no I was like John
we bought a dagger she takes it on the
boat and she's like mom's the one on the
bus right we're on the bus oh my god no
she has no shoes where do I keep it I
said alright by your bed I go just in
case someone breaks hey now you have a
dagger you've stabbed them that's the
coolest daughter of all time I have a
baseball bat next to my bed so I have
room to improve my wife fair at a forty
pound bull mat that you eat cake with
yeah bird we're at the end of the
podcast thank you so much for making
time this is super fun yeah where can
people find everything that you're doing
online on Netflix etc um you can just if
you go to Burt Burt Burt calm as be e RT
b RT b ERT
you can go to I know I should Pat for
right you can get you can find
everything you find my Twitter my
Instagram you can probably find my tour
dates and you can probably find a link
just go to Netflix the specials called
secret on
it starts streaming August 24th this is
way so it'll be fully available and
hopefully you guys have watched it
already by this point yeah and hopefully
you're like as soon as I said Pikachu
you're like oh my god yeah if you guys
honestly want to leave a review in the
iTunes Store for this episode if you
guys have seen the Pikachu moment please
let us know that would be very well
appreciated Bert thank you so much yeah
I would love that
well I'm just on your show on all things
comedy cooking show and speaking of food
this is every guest of the podcast gets
a personalized fortune cookie for being
here would you'll find out if it says
quit drinking oh I would never do that
to someone this is a soft one too yeah
we got a steam it open to put the
fortunes in and so they get a little
soft oh my god that's brilliant oh my
god you can steam a fortune cookie and
I'm doing that to my dog this is legit
personalized ah yeah it might be like a
diary entry okay go ahead this podcast
is also formerly challenging to
participate in another triathlon next to
mo just kidding next mo
just kidding that'd be crazy but also if
you do will do nothing either way yeah
okay yes Barry we subscribe to very
uninspiring fortunes yeah so you're
welcome for that and thanks I'll do
another triathlon and you guys don't
have to do anything well track the body
progress and see how it goes guys if you
haven't checked out bird on everything
please do he's absolutely think
fantastic and we'll see you guys next
time on another episode of not too deep
goodbye too deep toady Dodie third love
is passionate about the perfect fit and
they believe it's time for your bra to
fit you and not the other way around
their collections are designed by women
for women so you will love the way you
feel under each and every look and now
they offer over 70 sizes and more than a
dozen styles so you'll find the perfect
bra for every moment and every outfit
get 15% off your first purchase by going
to third love comm slash grace today not
too deep as a production of grace helbig
incorporated
do sir and directed by Jack ferry
producer and editor melissa demons
writing by Diane King production
assistants by Audrianna Monty agudo post
production sound by Chris Henry and an
extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]